اثنان من نجومها المتقاطعة بالنجوم يعبران
جسرًا مغطى بالثلوج، وهو
مشهد جميل صارخ من سلسلة HBO الناجحة The Last
of Us لكن المعجبين لا يمكنهم الانتظار ليكونوا
أول من يكتشف الفشل، هل تشاهد
الفيلم
الفيلم بأكمله  الطاقم هنا
لم يتمكنوا من مقاومة تكبير
أفراد الطاقم الواضحين، ليس فقط مجموعة واحدة ولكن
مجموعتين، هل حصل شخص ما على إشاراتهم،
وعبروا للحصول على نصيحة حول أفضل طريقة
للغرب والذهاب
إلى الشرق، حاول المشجعون مازحين دمج
أفراد الطاقم في حبكة العرض هذه
الأشخاص هنا هم
معجب آخر قام بالتغريد على إحدى
الحلقات الرائعة لأحد المبدعين بشيء
قد ترغب في إصلاحه، ثم أضاف
أكواب ستاربكس لتسليط الضوء على مكان وجود طاقم
الفيلم، حيث كانت رجال الشرطة
إشارة إلى لعبة Game of Thrones الشهيرة التي
تركوا فيها فنجان قهوة
قضى المشاهدون يومًا ميدانيًا في رسم
دوائر وسهام تشير إلى أن Gaff كان
شرطيًا ورقيًا عاديًا في فترة أكثر
ملاءمة للكؤوس والأبواق، على الرغم من أن
العرض اعترض على أنه لم يكن
ستاربكس في الواقع ومازح أن Latte الذي
ظهر في الحلقة كان خطأ
Daenerys.  لقد طلبنا شايًا عشبيًا،
كل ما يمكننا قوله هو أن هؤلاء هم بعض
المعجبين شديدي البصر بفيلم كريتون بأكمله
الذين انسكب كوبهم عندما وجدوا
خطأ
جيني بالقرب من سي إن إن نيويورك
[موسيقى]